le second débat dans cette émission
débat plus prospectif consacrée à
l'avenir du ps et à l'avenir d'anne
hidalgo à hidalgo hold up sur le ps
voilà le titre que l'on a choisi le
double mixte le double mixte c'est le
nom de la salle où se déroulait le 79ème
congrès ce week-end à villeurbanne à
hidalgo la jouer en solo elle n'était
pas présente elle a refusé aussi de
débattre avec ses contradicteurs en
attendant le vote des militants le 14
octobre samia de chiens elle n'était pas
présente ce week end mais le congrès du
ps ressemblait bien à une première
victoire d'anne hidalgo après la
réélection d'olivier fort à la tête du
parti
la maire de paris soutenu par la
quasi-totalité des poids lourds
socialistes est désormais sûre d'être
investie candidate à la présidentielle
le parti socialiste doit déterminer et à
mon avis rapidement quel candidat quelle
candidate soutien pour l'élection
présidentielle je sais avec certitude
qu'il soutiendra la candidature d'année
dalo c'est le souhait d'anne hidalgo
elle doit être la candidate soutenue par
les socialistes est soutenu à fond pour
obtenir l'investiture du parti elle doit
d'abord se soumettre à un vote interne
des militants face à l stéphane le foll
maire du mans et ancien ministre de
françois hollande un match sans suspense
et sans débat public la direction s'y
refuse je ne peux pas dire que nous
avons peur des critiques moi ce que j'ai
peur c'est de donner l'image d'un parti
à l'extérieur qui se déchirerait d'avoir
aux yeux des français qui n'ont que
faire de nos querelles d'avoir des
divisions qui souhaite étaler sur la
place publique pas du débat public donc
mais en échange en interne entre
candidats et militants les partisans de
la outsiders stéphane le foll dénonce un
déni de démocratie
oui il manque deux révèle dans ce parti
il manque de voix qui manquent de 2,2
deux confrontations quelle politique
économique
quelle politique étrangère quelle
politique européenne voilà ce qu'il faut
débattre de manière publique directe
contradictoires une critique partagée
par certains militants pourtant
favorable et la candidature d'ali
d'algues ou ça peut pas être une
décision verticale veut dire anne
hidalgo et la candidate à la
présidentielle
mais c'est un débat 100 naturel s'il ya
plusieurs candidats parce que blizzard a
quand même cas n'est pas le vote des
militants aura lieu le 14 octobre tous
savent que le match est déjà écrit avec
ou sans l'investiture du parti anne
hidalgo et de toute façon déjà candidate
à l'élection présidentielle
les chances d'anne hidalgo dans cette
élection présidentielle était en train
de réaliser un hold up sur le psc la
paix questions que l'on pose et que je
pose à mes invités j'accueille serge
raffy bonjour bienvenue vous ce soir
rédacteur en chef à l'ops vous publiez
ali d'algues ou une ambition qui vient
de loin c'est aux éditions bouquin
j'accueille le sénateur socialiste de
paris david assouline vous soutenez la
candidature de dany l'algo bienvenue à
vous aussi céline bracq bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes directrice de
l'institut de sondage au doxa matthieu
croissandeau évidemment il rester à mes
côtés david assouline je commence avec
vous je lisais dans le point vous avez
négocié au nom d'anne hidalgo pour
décider de l'organisation ou non d'un
débat avec stéphane le foll et jean
christophe cambadélis
ne s'est pas complètement comme ça au
congrès et il a été décidé de faire une
petite commission où les uns et les
autres discuter pour proposer une
procédure de désignation donc j'ai
défendu l'idée qu'il fallait un vote
souverain des militants comme on l'a
toujours fait et puis qu'il y ait eu un
échange des candidats avec
avec les militants dans un délai assez
rapprochées parce que de toute façon
faut être très vite maintenant il faut
il faut commencer a surtout pensé à
aller vers les françaises et les
français et anne hidalgo
consacrera l'essentiel de son temps à
partir de maintenant avec le fait
qu'elle est maire de paris tout ce
qu'elle pourra donner en plus ce sera
pour aller sur le terrain et notamment
discuter avec les abstentionnistes qui
il faut faire revenir à la politique et
ça veut dire qu'un débat c'est une perte
de temps non pas du tout je viens de
vous dire qu'il y aura un duel va
débattre a écrit militants mais avec
avec ce qui s'était déclaré candidat je
viens de vous répondre il y aura un
débat que la procédure va être encore
précisés sur la forme avec les militants
qui ou
des questions à lui posées sur ses
propositions sur son dessin sur sa
vision de la france et il y aura un vote
un vote complètement éclairé
avec une procédure qui a été décidé par
les statuts que c'est cette fois ci un
vote interne et donc un débat interne
alors je sais que vous préférez que vous
poussez chars sur les plateaux
sur ce plateau l'émission est jeune et
je fais pas que je parle traduit par je
sais très bien que on aime bien tout est
mise en scène mais nous on peut pas dire
qu'on a regardé ça avec dédain dans le
passé où l'a fait et là on a considéré
que dans ce moment de reconstruction de
de volonté de clarté
il n'y avait pas des différences énormes
qui s'était manifestée dans notre
congrès en termes d'orientation
politique distincte qui ont existé dans
le passé et donc qu'il fallait se merde
vitre en ordre de bataille autour d'une
candidature
est privilégiée je répète le débat avec
les citoyens plutôt que la mise en scène
de combat des ego parce qu'en plus vous
savez comme moi que il n'ya pas
disons
de concurrence ou de grand suspense sur
le résultat de ce qui va être votée par
les militants très massivement oui
j'imagine que
c'est le foll va apprécier dans le jdd
il dit olivier forest hidalgo refuse le
débat j'en prends acte s'il n'y a plus
de débat au sein du ps c'est la mort du
parti tel qu'il a existé oui j'entends
ces découvertes sont dispo non je ne
chante je cherche à comprendre toujours
quand quelqu'un parle pourquoi quoi
qu'est-ce qu'il veut démontrer qu est ce
qu il veut dire or nous sortons d'un
moment de débat gigantesque il ya peu de
partis qui font ça nous c'est toutes nos
sections tous nos fédérations qui à
multiples reprises se réunissent tel
vote sur des textes d'orientation ont
élaboré un projet il ya eu des joutes du
projet parce que c'était il ya six mois
il fallait le faire en zone ouvert au
plus grand nombre
bon il va lovell calme belkacem boris
valent au pardon
mais donner le nom de sa femme
on pourrait aussi
à a
rassemblé ça tout le monde a jugé que ce
document de plus de 60 pages est un vrai
document avec un vrai projet à mettre
sur la table pour les français tout ça
ça a été des bas je n'ai pas vu une
seule fois stéphane le foll ni participé
ni émettre une opinion sur tout ce
travail et j'ai vient d'un congrès
puisque je viens de passer deux jours
avec les militants à villeurbanne je
n'ai pas vu stéphane le foll or il ya eu
des dizaines d'interventions il aurait
pu se dire que puisque le parti est
important ils viennent dire devant ce
parti au moment suprême d'un congrès ce
qu'il pensait mais il préfère le dire
dans les médias dont j'ai l'impression
qu'il ya quelque chose qui est plutôt la
voulons
la volonté d'ab science que de
construire ensemble une alternative pour
la journée à la question du débat et ce
titre hold up sur le ps est-ce que vous
ressentez
voilà la stratégie d'al gore depuis
quelques jours le fait qu'elle soit pas
venu au congrès le fait qu'elle se soit
déclaré finalement face aux français
avant même d'avoir reçu l'investiture de
des militants comme une forme de ça va
déjà le fait le fait qu'elles ne
viennent pas à ce congrès a fait que ce
congrès n'a intéressé personne pardon et
je dire médiatiquement c'est quand même
le désert donc ça c'est un vrai problème
c'est vrai que c'est eric zemmour qui a
occupé tout le terrain pendant deux
jours médiatiquement le congrès du parti
socialiste est pratiquement passée à la
trappe donc ça c'est un problème sur le
fond dans l'histoire du parti socialiste
il ya toujours eu des votes des
militants lionel jospin a été désignée
par un vote militant donc c'était tout
pour le parti tout sur le parti ensuite
il y a eu françois hollande qui a été
lui désigné par une primaire et ça a été
un succès et une primaire très digne et
c'est le problème c'est qu'il ya pas de
bonnes recettes tout dépend de la
conjoncture et tout dépend des
circonstances historiques ensuite on a
vu le désastre benoît hamon mais qui
était déjà un écrit pratiquement
politiquement avant même la primaire
parce que déjà le parti était est et
était beaucoup habib est donc là on se
retrouve effectivement devant un premier
secrétaire fragile malgré tout même s'il
a été élu assez facilement au congrès à
plus 70 % des welsches dirais pas que
c'est soviétique mais c'est quand même
assez énorme mais il ya une sensation
d'années me du parti socialiste d'un
malgré tout malgré ce que dit david
assouline et je comprends ce qu'il dit
mais il ya quand même pour le grand
public l'impression qu'il n'ya pas de
grands débats au parti socialiste sur
quand même les grandes questions qui se
posent aujourd'hui même si à ce projet
s'il ya ces 60 pages etc médiatiquement
tout ça n'est pas apparu au grand public
alors si on élargit maintenant et on se
projette un petit peu dans l'avenir
c'est une braque la question des chances
quand vous analysez la candidature d'ali
d'algos qu'est ce qui ressort peut-être
on va commencer par les points positifs
et puis ensuite vous mettez en avant les
faibles je voulais réagir aussi ces
termes de hold up encore faut-il qu hier
un butin on fera voler quand on parle de
hold up pour le moment le butin est un
peu maigre et elle n'a pas une
concurrence absolument extraordinaire au
sein du parti socialiste et c'est
d'ailleurs un des atouts d'anne hidalgo
c'est à dire que certes le ps so grince
ça grince un peu des dents mais il ya
personne qui s'impose face à elles de
manière évidente donc ça c'est un atout
c'est une personnalité politique qui est
connu en france à paris mais pas
seulement à paris en france c'est une
personnalité politique connue et qui a
été élu et très bien réélu et l egypte
quelqu'un de battant c'est pas une
apparatchik c'est une personne qui a
voilà qui a grimpé petit à petit les
échelons qui a qui a été élu une
première fois à paris etc etc après
est-ce que connu ça veut forcément dire
populaire non bien sûr que non et je
suis justement le problème c'est qu'elle
est impopulaire anne hidalgo auprès de
la majorité des français il ya deux
tiers des français qui rejettent la
personnalité d'un hidalgo alors certes
c'est évidemment beaucoup mieux qu' on
resserre sur les sympathisants de gauche
si on resserre sur les sympathisants
socialistes ils sont les deux tiers
avoir une bonne image d'elle il faut
voir qu'aujourd'hui les sympathisants
socialistes c'est 6 % des français et
encore ces 6 % de français on a vu par
exemple que lors de la dernière
présidentielle en 2017 ils étaient
minoritaires à voter pour benoît hamon
et cette fois ci on a pour le moment en
tout cas je sais pas ce que ça va donner
je pense que ça va faire partie de votre
travail dans les mois qui viennent une
gauche absolument morcelé et des
écologistes qui avaient voté assez
massivement si l'on peut dire benoît
hamon et qui cette fois ci bas auront a
priori leur candidat ou leur candidate
mathieu je pense pas qu'elle fasse un
hold up sur le ps elle est en position
de force donc les dicte ses conditions
après comme l'a dit céline ya pas de
concurrence ce qui étonne c'est dans la
tradition du parti socialiste vont se
targuer plutôt de faire primer les idées
sur les personnes là on a une personne
karine dont on connaît pas vraiment les
idées puisqu'il ya pas de projet et ce
projet n'est même pas mis en débat
puisqu'il y aura pas d ça c'est aussi
étonnant parce que quand on se souvient
serge a rappelé oui lionel jospin mais
il ya eu ségolène royal qui a fait trois
débats face à deux contradicteurs qui
étaient déployés au quai des arts à
dominique strauss kahn laurent fabius et
même avant si on remonte à mitterrand
début en tout cas un congrès de metz par
exemple qui avait tranché la ligne entre
eurocae mitterrand sur l'élection
suivante les marocains à tenter quelque
chose puis finalement il a relancé mais
il y avait cette tradition de combat
d'idées là aujourd'hui david assouline
ne dit qu'un projet du parti socialiste
mais là encore est ce que ça sera le
projet d'agglo non on le sait
traditionnellement la sepa spécifique
anne hidalgo un candidat on fait
toujours son projet à côté et voilà et
françois hollande l'avait fait à côté du
parti et après avoir été
dans le même temps ce qui est très
particulier quand même c'est cette
absence de projet les généralement les
le projet précède la candidature dans
dans l'histoire deux des candidats
socialistes on sait d'où ils viennent
c'est des gens consignes et des joues
donne un exemple très très par très
parlant anne hidalgo à fédérer autour
d'elle une équipe et c'est vrai que
c'est plutôt des jeunes mères c'est des
jeunes mères qui viennent d'horizons
divers au ps carole delga était valls
east et scan hidalgo et valls east je ne
le pense pas mathieu klein le maire de
nancy d'ailleurs matière et pardon
encore elle ne les a pas fédérer au
départ se sont vraiment eux
et qu'ils ont poussé parce qu'il ya cinq
ans
ça n'a pas marché comme ça c'est
vraiment les élus tous cette génération
des cadres à du parti socialiste
matthieu à raison qui eux se sont réunis
bien avant pour savoir mais qui pourrait
incarner quelque chose on peut dire
qu'ils sont allés la chercher quelque
part dire qu'elle fait là c'est rien sur
cela mais sur quels fonds sur quel
projet pour l'instant on en a pas la
moindre idée tu nous a dit si oui je
pense qu'il ya des approximations lent
dans ce que vous dites parce que en
réalité carole delga personnes dans la
caractériser comme bâle 6 parce que
dans la soute du manuel valls laden le
sénat donc ça vous aimez ça veut
absolument rien dire aujourd'hui c'est à
dire que l homme l époque c'est d'aller
au clash socialistes et les tout le
monde sait qui et carole delga à peu
près quel type de de politique elle
défend pas seulement par les mots mais
parce qu'elle réalise en occitanie et
c'est la présidente de région la mieux
élue dont je ne pense pas qu'on ne sait
pas ce qu'elle dit ce qu'elle pense
qu'elle quelle vision elle a dû social
de l'écologie mais c'est un carnet c'est
à dire c'est dans la pratique et les
français d'occitanie par exemple savent
beaucoup plus qui est carole delga que
les commentateurs apparemment donc
ensuite si je prends le maire de nancy
pareil c'est bien
ça voulait dire quelque chose tu es une
vision du
stade j l'art aujourd'hui on est tous
ont écrit on écrit une nouvelle page on
écrit une nouvelle page alors que
propose anne hidalgo par son parcours
par sa vie elle va se faire connaître
autrement que comme la maire de paris
simplement la maire de paris aujourd'hui
on voit des sondages je suis appelé pour
un sondage le sujet habite je ne sais
pas à marseille ou à lyon ou ailleurs on
me dit anne hidalgo je pense tout de
suite maire de paris d'accord quand on
me dit emmanuel maquereau ou jean luc
mélenchon qui s'est fait présenter deux
fois une troisième fois et là je pense
vision du pays je connais son histoire
je sais qu'il est etc etc et présidence
de la république donc maintenant elle va
aller à la rencontre des français elle a
commencé pour qu'ils sachent qui elle
était une femme française fille
d'immigrés espagnols ouvriers qui a
grandi à lyon et qui comme beaucoup de
jeunes sont venus à paris pour avoir un
avenir professionnel
elle a choisi le social inspectrice
inspectrice du travail est elle à les
rentrer en politique par le meilleur des
meilleurs des fonctions ou joints les
idées et la pratique et on voit les
réalisations on est remis en cause à
l'instant t quand on fait les choses on
doit se remettre en question et revenir
sur le mât sur l'avant et elle a fait ça
à paris par deux fois on à le juger car
était plutôt compétentes et elle a
rassemblé la gauche parce qu'aux caisses
house ce côté trop page l'a pas encore à
et parvenir à ce que c'est quand même
très important cette histoire de deux
hold-up sur le parti socialiste suis
d'accord et goussé par le dup etc moi je
ne dirais que c'est un chapardage c'est
à dire que c'est une manière assez
habile deux en même temps s'appuyer sur
le paie le parti socialiste tout en y
allant avec des avec des
avec des gants ouh là là il faut pas que
je me suis trop les doigts là dedans
mais ceci dit dans son histoire
politique anne hidalgo n'a jamais été
une apparatchik elle a toujours été en
lisière elle a toujours eu des gros
problèmes avec les grandes les grandes
batailles d'idées au sein du parti
socialiste non pas parce qu'elle n'a pas
d'idées mais parce qu'elle a toujours
été très méfiante deux de ces batailles
des des éléphants du parti socialiste
parce que d'abord elle n en était pas un
elle était bon très aubrystes on sait
très bien quelle a été ma rennais entre
guillemets par matip par martine aubry
pendant plus de dix ans c'est à dire que
sa carrière quand même la doit
essentiellement à martine aubry il faut
pas l'oublier donc elle était et un peu
bertrand delesne bertrand delanoë sont
là on lui un peu forcé la main pour
l'apprendre au départ ils en voulaient
pas un bertrand delanoë ça c'est fait
d'une manière très compliqué c'était
aussi lui qui avait envie qu'ils
voulaient faire plaisir aussi à martine
aubry et à fait blancs dans celle qui va
un clash avec bertrand delanoë quand
elle a été potentiellement candidate à
la mairie tous quand c'était françois
hollande on est en 2004 c'est ça et
c'est à dire que l'oeil avide de placer
livre à compte à tous là j'avoue j'étais
moi même très surpris de découvrir les
relations pour le moins complexes entre
anne hidalgo delanoë c'était vraiment
incroyablement tendu et donc anne
hidalgo en fait au bout de quelques
années à la mairie de paris alors
qu'elle est première adjointe la fameuse
période voit les adjointe au bureau
première adjointe au bureau des temps ça
va on l'appelait l'horloge parlante à
l'époque on se moquait laine pour nos
personnels pour parler poliment elle
s'ennuie pas à les humilier elle se sent
trahis humiliés et elle veut partir et
elle le dit et à martine aubry et à
françois hollande je ne veux pas rester
à paris et donc là il ya une opération
qui se montrent par françois hollande
qui a quand même la rhd de toujours
pareil l'art de l'esquivé il ya une
possibilité à toulouse tu devrais y
aller elle a fait effectivement un petit
voyage à toulouse et elle a tâté le
terrain pour savoir si c'était jouable
elle s'est rendue compte ça prouve
qu'elle est quand même très habile elle
s'est rendu compte que toulouse c'était
très compliqué parce que là aussi les
militants et ça c'est très compliqué de
savoir l'appui des militants d'une
fédération comme celle de la
haute-garonne alors trop parisienne mal
a répondu anne hidalgo c'était sur
france inter lundi dernier écouter en
cube déplacent partout que ce soit en
ardèche que ce soit dans le massif
central en occitanie en bretagne dans le
nord les gens sont venus me parler non
pas du fait que j'étais maire de paris
il était plutôt d'ailleurs comptant
beaucoup d'entre eux m'ont dit c'est
bien que l'on vienne nous voir et qu'on
vienne nous écouter je pense qu'il ya un
besoin vraiment de parole
d'expression à hauteur d'hommes et de
femmes de ce qui se passe dans la vraie
vie des gens et il se trouve que par mon
histoire personnelle je viens d'un
milieu très populaire de l'immigration
espagnole j'ai eu la chance de
bénéficier de cet ascenseur
républicain je connais la vraie vie vous
savez je connais la vraie vie c'est une
baraque c'est l'un des défis de d'anne
hidalgo peut-être de s'adresser à
l'électorat populaire aussi oui parce
que c'est un vrai sujet c'est à dire que
quand je le disais tout à l'heure
qu'elle était à ses fins même très
impopulaire auprès de l'ensemble des
français anne hidalgo c'est notamment
parce que elle est jugée comme quelqu'un
de peu proche des gens c'est comme ça
qu'elle est vue pour le moment est par
ailleurs
à l'élue parisienne mais c'est pas
seulement provinces-unies tous contre
paris c'est aussi que l ai connu anne
hidalgo notamment pour son combat contre
la voiture et
dans beaucoup de parties de la france se
dire qu'on a quelqu'un qui s'oppose à la
voiture se dit qu'il faut la limiter au
maximum alors qu'on n'a pas encore
forcément une alternative pour faire
autrement points voilà j'ai quand même
ça serait ce pas forcément très bien et
elle est vue aussi comme quelqu'un
intervenants beaucoup sur des sujets
sociétaux plus que sociaux donc là aussi
c'est un travail qu'il aura à faire
c'est-à-dire prouver qu'elle peut être
la candidate et sociale du parti
socialiste ce qui n'est pas le cas pour
le moment c'est vrai que l ai vu plus
tôt et elle est plutôt appréciée par des
catégories qui sont plutôt des
catégories supérieures plutôt que des
catégories populaires difficile de
relever ce défi quand même
est ce que par exemple le son premier
acte fort dans la campagne c'est
évidemment la hausse des salaires c'est
sa proposition sur le salaire des des
professeurs et de tous ceux qui sont en
contact avec avec avec les enfants c'est
aussi pour gommer pour gommer cette
dimension quel point cette direction oui
je vais vous répondre que vous dites ce
serait difficile ce serait difficile si
c'était
la fabrication d'une image c'est à dire
s'il fallait inventer une image de ce qu
elle n'est pas et qui serait cet image
sociale or c'est très facile il va
falloir juste le faire connaître le fait
le faire savoir le plus simplement
possible
c'est pas forcément des émissions télé
c'est sur le terrain
ce qu'elle est ce qu'elle est c'est à
dire que quand elle dit je connais la
vraie vie c'est vrai est beaucoup plus
que la majorité de la classe politique
que je connais qui n'arrête pas de
parler du peuple d'accord
que la lal élève ces enfants là une vie
professionnelle elle elle conjugue tout
ce que la vie quotidienne fait mais
aussi ses origines et pour comprendre sa
fibre sociale de gauche on va dire qui
va bien au delà du parti socialiste qui
a ses racines dans la république
espagnole son grand père était un
condamné à mort pas franco c'est dense
et ça se portent presque dans les gènes
ces choses là et son engagement à la
grandi dans des quartiers populaires je
sais son empathie pour la cause sociale
la justice sociale est ce qu'on ne dit
pas à paris parce que le combat urgent
d'aujourd'hui grande vide bien entendu
que c'est l'écologie bien entendu que
quand il ya le métro le tramway quand on
peut aller au boulot de façon rapide
avec tous les transports en commun
possible et elle et les transports
alternatifs
bien entendu que la voiture est une
aberration mais elle ne dit pas que
c'est la même chose pour n'importe quel
ouvrier en france et qu'il est dans un
endroit où je traîne ça c'est je
voudrais sur l'écologie sur les quatre
agrès de nous dire qu'il ne faudra
laisser personne sur le bord du chemin
et que ça doit s'accompagner
non mais il ya quand même eu l'idée
initiale très fort on a bien entendu
rapport à ce qu'a dit céline bracq il ya
un grand défi il ya celui qui a été dit
c'est à dire la parisienne
l'ennemi de la voiture etc et en prêt en
région c'est évident que c'est un
problème pour tous les jugements de
région
c'est un truc très dur à combattre et
l'autre chose qui est très importante
qui est un défi politique à mon avis
majeur c'est que anne hidalgo elle s'est
construite en tant que maire de paris à
l'international elle a été présidente du
c40 ce fameux groupe des grandes
métropoles métropoles mondiales sur une
posture politique très intéressante qui
était une posture de contre-pouvoir par
rapport à l'état nation c'est-à-dire
l'idée était qui était porté d'ailleurs
pas seulement par l par des dizaines de
grands mères des grandes métropoles
mondiales qu'aujourd'hui les
contre-pouvoirs c'était les grandes
métropoles mondiales qui était beaucoup
plus compétente beaucoup plus capable de
lutter en particulier quand le
réchauffement climatique et dans les
faits on l'a vu par exemple aux états
unis face à trump qui avait tout un tas
de maires de grandes villes que ça en
californie ou ailleurs en russie ce
matin kim et qui menait le combat pour
la chaux panther avoir métropole deux
ans et elle millions d'habitants est là
quand elle a construit un corpus
idéologique une doxa si je puis dire sur
cette idée là sur ces listings s'est
ensuite que la grande métropole mondiale
c'était l'avenir or aujourd'hui bas il
faut aller
il faut aller tremper les les sabots
dans la glaise n'a jamais dit que les
métros tout paul doivent remplacer elle
a dit que tout à fait mais quand même
c'était
réservé au sein du bief mais que si avec
les équipes ce serait beaucoup mieux et
d'avis maintenant ça va être les limites
elle c'est faux savez très bien que ce
débat là vous les avez vous l'avez dans
les équipes d'analystes qui souhaite un
débat tout à fait intéressant bien géré
fille qu'est ce qui pourrait nous
surprendre parce que
une campagne présidentielle c'est la
rencontre d'un daim ou une candidate
avec le peuple est effectivement on
l'entend même dans votre discours davila
solis il s'agit de faire découvrir
anne hidalgo son histoire personnelle
son histoire familiale qu'est ce qui
peut avoir c'est par ici à des mystères
dans le personnage et j'ai découvert en
écrire une biographie sur elle donc avec
beaucoup quand même plus de 25 heures
d'entretiens en tête à tête c'est que
cette femme et est inoxydable
dans le livre je l'appelle miss titane
c'est qu'elle se relève de tout lui elle
prendre coup et plus elle est plus large
donc c'est quand même ce qui m'intéresse
toujours dans mes biographie c'est
qu'est ce qui fait avancer un personnage
pour avoir cette idée saugrenue se
vouloir est tout seul à la tête d'un
pays donc ça c'est quelque chose qui à
chaque fois moi me passe me passionne et
donc chez elle je cherchais ça et alors
c'est ce que ce que david a dit c'est
vrai c'est à dire que son humus ouvriers
etc son père est la commune étaient dix
ans spectris du travail elle a été dix
ans inspectrice du travail non pas comme
ça dans les dents dans la haute sphère
mai à saint-etienne dans des villes où
elle a vécu de très près le déclassement
de la classe ouvrière le la fin de
certaines industries etc il était
confronté concrètement tous les jours à
ce genre de question donc ce n'est pas
quelqu'un qui aime à paris n'a jamais
fait l'ena et c'est donc c'est un
personnage qui est beaucoup plus
intéressant qu'il n'y paraît simplement
jusqu'à présent c'est quelqu'un qui
avance et quand même beaucoup masqué
c'est à dire qu'ils avancer
tranquillement un peu même en mode crabe
toujours sur le côté parce que c'est une
femme et que c'est compliqué c'est un
débat qu'on a eue avant de rentrer ici
pour être au dernier étage vers l'iss
faites-le pour être partie voilà les
deux noms mais c'est à lire des poèmes
une femme et bien c'est beaucoup plus
dur pour elle que pour un homme
d'accéder aux plus hautes fonctions elle
a vécu elle pendant très longtemps elle
a été humiliée un nombre de fois magique
et pour ça le fait se livre aussi
possible mais comment elle fait pour
résister à toutes ces saloperies qu'elle
a pris ses soutes purin qu'elle a pris
sur la sur la tête pendant pendant des
années donc ça c'était très intéressant
et je pense qu'aujourd'hui ce travail là
ce travail de découverte se découvrir
c'est à dire c'est à elle elle doit non
seulement découvrir faire découvrir aux
français qu'ils allaient mais pour le
faire il faut qu'elle se découvre
vraiment et ce qu'elle doit un peu forcé
sa nature d'ailleurs nous sommes assez
costauds dans sprycel doit se presser
basques eux aussi l s'agit de faire
découvrir aux français une qui est laid
et ce qu'elle veut bah il reste peu de
temps et c'est ça mon avis une 2d
problématique pour elle c'est vrai
qu'elle est identifiée les connue comme
la maire de paris mais pas que des
devises a raison
alors voilà donc elle doit construire
son image et en même temps a emmené les
français vers ce qu'elle veut et c'est
là bas très longtemps à ce moment du
délai qui nous fait pas l'élection
présidentielle voir avec le fait qu'elle
est encore pas connu dans toute sa
dimension par les français elle est
nettement plus que manuel mac on pouvait
mettre à la même date oui bien sûr elle
est plus identifiés ont
été en retard
je pense qu'on est
également été identifiés sur un projet
il avait des axes forts l'axé fort qu'on
connaît ou à tort ou à raison mais qu'on
a reçu de nidal gosset la transition
écologique était globalement les
français associé à ça celle qui à marche
forcée disent les uns avec du
volontarisme disent les autres est en
train de transformer la capitale mais sa
chance il aurait sinon je alors de
l'urgence climatique et je
sais fonds et s'est vu de plus en plus
comme un sujet important pour les gens
mais c'est vu comme un sujet important
mais pas prioritaire ça veut dire que du
coup à un candidat à la présidentielle
est obligé de pouvoir qu'on voit sur
tous les autres sujets pêche et c'est
vrai que quand on a une image déjà
associé à un domaine et que les gens ont
l'impression déjà de bien vous connaître
sans doute à tort et bien c'est plus
compliqué de pouvoir modifier cette
image là encore plus si un candidat issu
de la primaire écologiste souvenons
maintenant et c'est de se positionner
sur les mêmes thèmes ce sera peut-être
une chance parce que si par exemple
c'est sandrine rousseau qui était élu il
peut y avoir une déstabilisation au sein
d'europe écologie les verts qui fait que
peut-être certains vont venir vous voir
et vous vouloir parler avec vous et de
vous souhaiter la victoire de sandrine
rousseau et je veux vraiment pas
interférer je me disais que je n'y ai
pas 15 mai mais je je je veux aussi dire
la bo de la victoire de cinsault anne
hidalgo part qu'elle est élue à paris
c'est quand même assez clair je vis
depuis 40 ans dans le 20e arrondissement
l élu par les quartiers populaires de
paris c'est à dire par les quartiers qui
ressemble plus à la france
et donc je pense que elle n'aura pas de
difficulté à parler à la france parce
que elle elle sait les convaincre et ces
gens-là de ces quartiers ne vote pas
uniquement sur l'écologie où les
préoccupations des cas tu pètes sais
mais c'est là où il ya le logement
social c'est là où il ya les politiques
de solidarité sociale et plus fort c'est
là où il ya les prises en charge de tout
ce qui est grand défi le temps d'une
campagne électorale à bord a changé
aussi c'est beaucoup reconnu comme celle
où sinon elle ne serait pas maire de
paris qui conjugue cette nécessité de
faire la transition écologique avec une
politique de solidarité puisque enfin et
les vertes dans sa majorité parle des
chances de l'hidalgo il faut aussi
parler de ses concurrents quentin calmez
vous pouvez nous rejoindre pour un
éclairage sur la candidature d'arnaud
on veut travailler de caillou dans la
chaussure c'est ça oui et puis ça qu'on
l'a suivi thomas tout au long de l'été
dans les organes dans les éléments qui
étaient organisées par le ps que ce soit
eh bien les universités d'été qui se
tenait à blois où les journées
parlementaires vos journées david
assouline quand c'était à montpellier à
chaque fois composer cette question lors
de nos reportages à une dalle go sur sa
candidature d'arnaud montebourg eh bien
elle le botté en touche systématiquement
regarder un exemple quand on y était
avec eux j'ai attendu prises d'abord je
vais pas voilà chacun a le droit de
venir présenter sa proposition de venir
essayer de se faire entendre des
françaises et des français et je
respecte toutes celles et ceux qui se
lancent dans l'aventuré politique parce
que je sais qu'elle n'est pas simple
cette aventure politique donc je n'ai
rien à répondre si je ne ferai aucun
commentaire il n'en fallait pas moins
pour y voir un pacte de non-agression
entre les deux et comme si les deux
prétendants issus la famille socialiste
est bien ne devait pas à s'attaquer l'un
l'autre et ça a été dit dans un article
du monde je vais vous le montrer cet
article de jeudi dernier on y voit cette
phrase en juin lors d'un déjeuner la
maire de paris et arnaud montebourg top
sur un pacte de non-agression et qui
fait donc aboutir un ralliement au
second à la première si le trou est fait
l'idée générale portée par les soutiens
d'hidalgo c'est que montebourg pour à se
rallier dans plusieurs mois écouter
quand on avait posé de questions un des
plus proches soutiens des d'agos et rémi
féraud anne hidalgo ne va pas être
candidate contre les autres candidats de
gauche elle va porter une dynamique je
pense que c'est celle qui est le mieux à
même de rassembler ceux qui voudront se
rassembler pour donner une chance à la
gauche de gagner
sellal ennemi qu'elle va dans le sens de
nos montebourg elle pourrait se ranger
derrière lui je crois que c'est une
question complètement théorique
changement de ton un quota de la part
d'arnaud montebourg ce week-end oui tout
à fait c'est comme si toute cette petite
musique autour d'un ralliement et d'une
dynamique et bien qu'elle était un
distillées par le camp hidalgo ça
commençait un peu à énerver passablement
le camp montebourg alors ce week-end
effectivement à l'intéressé a eu cette
petite phrase est cash lors d'une
interview de france 3 à propos d'un
rassemblement à terme écouter comme des
millions de français je me suis fait
avoir donc je recommencerai pas ce que
j'ai déjà fait c'est à dire mais j'ai
défendu finalement le parti socialiste
et comme des millions de français je me
suis fait avoir je recommencerai pas et
je ne recommencerai pas avec la fille
spirituelle de françois hollande hidalgo
c'est la fille spirituelle de françois
hollande
voilà en tout cas d'accord hidalgo on ne
nous confirme pas l existence de ce
pacte de non agression mais on s'agace
de ses attaques envers anne hidalgo de
la part de monde bourque et bien il est
vu en train de caresser et xavier
bertrand nous dit on effectivement ils
se sont un peu affichés ensemble l'hiver
dernier et ça ça agace passablement
effectivement dans le camp hidalgo merci
quand un fils spirituel de françois
hollande j'imagine que vous voulez
répondre non non moi j'ai pas envie de
rentrer dans la polémique mais je me
souviens dans la primaire socialiste
ouverte moi je soutenais martine aubry
et anne hidalgo aussi d'ailleurs et
arnaud montebourg une fois battu au
premier tour a appelé à voter françois
hollande à la surprise générale parce
que tout le monde pensait qu'il était
plutôt un proche de la gauche ou de
d'exigences plus à gauche donc je
rappellerai juste cela sens caractériser
ce qu'il a dit c'est d'ailleurs une
attaque ça montre qu'ils ont du mal à
attaquer anne hidalgo je pense à arnaud
montebourg là mais c'est une attaque on
entend beaucoup dans la france a
soumises à de dire il a le goût des
lowlands et on a déjà vu ça ce qui fait
actuellement au faut enfin gérer parce
qu'en plus il n'y a pas eu de proximité
n'a pas participé au gouvernement il
faut le dire il n'y a pas là bas elle
n'a pas être tributaire ou héritière et
la même été vendeuse du bilan voilà donc
c'est une brac arnaud montebourg
vous l'avez sont déjà il est ils
fragilisent la candidature d'ali l'algo
donne pas grand chose en intentions de
vote arnaud montebourg il est présent de
2% je crois non 2% voilà seulement c'est
un 17 n'est ce pas à gauche candidat de
gauche et c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup
d'éparpillement et toutes ces voix là
finalement cela fait une somme plutôt
pas mal puisqu'on a à peu près un quart
de voix qui se porte actuellement sur
les intentions de vote est encore loin
de la présidentielle sur des candidats
de gauche ça veut dire que contrairement
à ce qui peut être dit enfin des deux
choses d'ailleurs ne sont pas
incompatibles on dit souvent les
français se droitise dans certains cas
c'est vrai pour sur les sujets de la
sécurité de l'immigration c'est vrai
aussi sur la défense de l'entreprise
maintenant il ya beaucoup de français
qui se disent de gauche qui se sentent
de gauche qui trouve que le président
actuel est beaucoup trop à droite et
donc il ya vraiment quelque chose une
possibilité seulement si les
candidatures à l'amour se multiplient et
ne se réunissent pas autour d'un
candidat un moment ça va faire mal et ça
va rendre la tâche extrêmement difficile
mais arnaud bourg il a une qualité c'est
que c'est un sniper redoutable donc à
chaque fois il cogne et souvent ça fait
mal donc il peut quand même être un peu
nuisibles si je puis dire la candidature
d'un idéal ou simplement là en
l'occurrence danse convient d'attendre
la fille spirituelle de françois
hollande c'est une grosse bêtise qu'il
dit parce que c'est vraiment totalement
faux parce que tout le quinquennat de
françois hollande anne hidalgo a quand
même été souvent en opposition mais
frontale avec avec françois hollande n'a
jamais été pour des raisons multiples
pour des raisons politiques mais aussi
pour des raisons de posture par rapport
à la mairie de paris anne hidalgo depuis
qu elle est maire de paris en poste elle
a toujours eu cette espèce d'obsession
de vouloir représenter une vie
indépendante rebelles etc la ville de la
commune qui est toujours contre l'état
donc si je reviens ce que je disais tout
à l'heure son problème d'être contre
l'état aujourd'hui elle veut diriger
l'état tant que son grand travail ça va
être de dire comment je vais diriger
l'état aujourd'hui puisque moi pendant
des années j'étais pas vraiment une
folle
soutien de l'état français tels qu'ils
fonctionnaient alors si elle nous fait
des propositions claires et nettes sur
la manière dont elles voient l'état
nation aujourd'hui ça ça va m'intéresser
mais sérieusement elle va beaucoup le
faire de propositions se basant
d'ailleurs sur son équipe de mer pour
une nouvelle étape de la
décentralisation à dire elle considère
que l'organisation des pouvoirs d'hôtel
modifié que la place de l'état des
collectivités créera doit être repensé
globalement pour l'efficacité de
l'action publique est donc là
alors après il aura toute la crédibilité
d'ailleurs pour le proposait je pense
c'est une réforme fondamentale qu'il
faut payer y compris pour faire la
transition énergétique parce que c'est
c'est bien tous ces étages qui va
falloir agir mais qui sont une
conclusion maintenant qu'ils sont pas
forcément des thématiques première pour
les lecteurs il va aussi falloir parler
retraite savoir parler je le sais car la
fiscalité sécurité santé et là c'est
vrai qu'on attend de voir si elle
s'inscrit dans ce qu'on a connus au
parti socialiste et aime ce qu'elle sera
à sa façon ou à son corps défendant
l'héritière du hollandisme et avant et
avant leur disent autre chose ou est ce
qu'elle sera novatrices parce que elle
avancera de nouvelles par exemple les
faire la même chose que c'est pour cela
qu'on dit d'ailleurs qu'il ya pas de
raison qu'on sera sentent pas un moment
c'est sur les idées arnaud montebourg
insiste beaucoup sur la
réindustrialisation lareau localisation
c'est l'objet en ce moment de son
principal travail au formuler des
propositions et l'amant 60 de l'émission
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat on se retrouve demain pour un
nouveau sens public et puis n'oubliez
pas
ne ratez pas demain qu'il est je vous
cite le livre oui oui anne hidalgo une
ambition qui vient de loin c'est celle
du cas c'est le livre de serge raffy
voilà c'est simple détenus